okay as always our recordings of our
virtual meetups will be available on
youtube about a week after the meetup
and we'll post a message on youtube when
the recording is ready
next i am very pleased to introduce our
speaker today yamanchua kowal
himanshu kul is an associate professor
in the department of applied mathematics
at illinois institute of technology
he is a member of the discrete applied
math group
his interests lie broadly speaking in
discrete mathematics and operations
research especially graph theory
discrete in network optimization and
related mathematical and statistical
models and algorithms
and interdisciplinary
applications in transportation networks
computer science and ece power networks
and optimization
he is also interested in the ethical
aspects of mathematical and optimization
models and particularly in equitable
allocation of resources
so i'm very happy to pass it over to you
himachu
uh thank you very much uh thank you for
the introduction and thank you for the
invitation particularly to dr choi
i'm i i think this talk will be i mean i
when i discussed this with uh
searching with dr choi earlier i think
this would be an unusual talk because
i'm not going to talk so much about
the computational aspects of the
research that we did but more from a
more ethical or more philosophical
perspective of how we apply or how we
create mathematical models which are
used in all sorts of applications these
days whether you
use them you apply them with help of
computer programs or machine learning or
anything like any of the new hot
buzzwords in in the computational world
but i want to talk step back a little
bit and talk a little bit about
a fundamental ethical perspective
towards doing something like this so
thank you for being here let me share my
screen
and feel free to
stop me or interrupt me anytime you have
any questions
i will i love
discussing this stuff it will be a very
high level talk we won't really get into
too many details but if you have any
questions
anything you want clarified
please don't hesitate to i won't be able
to keep track of the chat but our
organizer has very kindly
will kindly help me and tell me if there
are any questions in the chat otherwise
you can unmute yourself and speak as
well we have a small enough group i
think that would be fine
okay
so i'm going to start with this
i'm going to talk a little bit about
ethics and mathematical modeling
and and then give you an example about
applying those ideas in in the context
of public transit network design
so this includes uh work with my former
phd student adam ramf who's at florida
polytechnic
so
so okay so mathematical models you know
so
mathematical models are a big question
in sciences engineering social sciences
and so on because they serve as a
conceptual representation of some
observed phenomena that we are trying to
understand so some
some common examples of
of mathematical models are some of some
some of you who took uh you know
newtonian physics in high school or
something like that classical mechanics
you throw a ball
what is the trajectory of that ball how
does it travel and so on and so forth
motion of planets population growth uh
epidemiology which is very relevant
these days spread of diseases how do
diseases spread in a population
microeconomic models financial market
you know financial models
how do you
create derivatives how you put
financial portfolios together what is
risk
risk management things like that all of
those and many many more
all of those models all of these models
are in all these applications are
mathematical descriptions of some
observed phenomena you create that
mathematical model and then you work
with that model to sort of understand
the phenomena that you're trying to
study
so
this is strange not showing
flight
for some reason okay doesn't matter
so
here's how here's a simplified version
of how the mathematical modeling process
works right so you're trying to
understand a real world behavior
you cannot understand and study each and
every detail of that so you pick based
on the kind of question you're trying to
answer you pick certain aspects of it
make some simplifying assumptions about
that and then you
write that description in a mathematical
language of some sort
you might be using variables it might be
an optimization model it might be an
economic model it might be some other
network model things like that it could
be any of those things it could be in
terms of differential equations
so you write a mathematical description
and then you analyze or solve that
mathematical description you come up
with some mathematical conclusions of
some sort i mean when i say analyze or
solve it could be an algorithm it could
be a program that you wrote which works
with that particular model analyzes
certain data that you already have and
you come up with some mathematical
conclusions based on that
because it's it's basically studying
this mathematical description
so then what you do is you interpret
what those mathematical solutions or
conclusions mean in the context of the
problem that you're trying to understand
that can be interpreted as an
explanation of the phenomena or
prediction depending on kind of model
you have
and then you check with the real life
observations that you have what you are
explaining or predicting actually
matches with what's happening in the
real world phenomena that you're trying
to understand right so there's a very
simple top level view of how this
process works
of course it's not as simple as this
loop like this in fact you know as you
set up a model as you analyze it you
might actually go back and you might
feed back into this step and redo that
step as you go this way as you look at
the interpretation you might realize oh
maybe i need to solve it in a different
way or i need to get
a different class of solutions and go
back over here or you might go back over
here and make some other assumptions
over here or as you go along and and you
do the value you realize that oh
the explanation or prediction does not
match with the real world behavior so i
need to go back and look at what
assumptions are made
so in terms of
in terms of math world versus real world
and i'm speaking of math as a very very
broadly
uh it is
you know bad or computational world
versus what's really happening in the
real world uh i mean so there is this
partition over here as you move from the
real world into the mathematical world
and then back into the real world
okay so this is just a
simple description of what what what we
try to do when we do when we use
mathematics in the real world
of course it goes without saying and
this is a very famous saying that all
model models are wrong but some are
useful right wrong in the sense that
no model can have
all
possible situations
you know included in itself i mean you
always have to make certain assumptions
and based on those assumptions you build
a model and try to do something with
that
but the reason we build models is
because we are trying to understand some
very complicated behavior we are trying
to uh experiment with a very complicated
or we are trying to predict what's going
to happen in the future based on some
complicated phenomena so
the reason these models are
any such situation is useful any such
description is useful is because it
might reveal relationships which are not
apparent superficially you might be able
to build strategies which are more
sophisticated or powerful than a naive
approach
and it allows for experimentation and
simulation when it's impossible or too
expensive to do in the video i mean
these days this is one of the big
reasons in computer science kind of
applications or computational
applications because you want to build a
simulation model or experimental model
where you can do things which would be
too expensive
so
so the question is now i want to focus
on this word wrong i mean i as i said
wrong it's talking about a one
particular thing right wrong in the
sense that you have to make certain
assumptions in your model you have to go
you have to go back
when you go through this very first step
right as you go through this very first
step over here
right
it's
annoying
give me a second
as you go through this step
you are
making certain assumptions which you
know technically makes your model wrong
but the power of the mathematical
modeling or power of doing these things
is by picking the right kind of
assumptions you make this is also the
source of the power of this particular
modeling process
so the art of modeling i always you know
when i talk to students about doing this
or or other collaborators it's not i
mean there is no scientific method by
which you can do step one step to step
three
even though a lot of practitioners may
try to make you believe that there is
this step one you put in all this data
into this black box and you get an
output actually to actually have a model
and something that you can make sense of
what's really going on
the art of making that modeling is not a
is not a precise step-by-step process
there is an art because you have to make
the right kind of choices in your setup
and the choices you make act as axioms
for your model
and they drive the whole model modeling
process from solution to interpretation
and things like that
so if you look at a couple of examples
like the classical
mechanics when you're talking about
throwing a ball and understanding is
trajectory or trying to understand the
motion of planets
there is an implicit assumption that
mass is fixed it acts like a point so
it's a point mass
forces act instantaneously
this worried newton as well as well as
all the way to
einstein that how can forces act
instantaneously but that is an
assumption you're making that it acts
interesting instantaneously and then you
have things like newton's law of motion
and then if you go on later to 20th
century we understand actually these
implicit assumptions are actually even
more
relevant in the sense of when you talk
about relativity or relativistic
mechanics you are talking about an
assumption which says these we are
working with an inertial frame of
reference non-relativity non-quantum
kind of a setup because when you drop
some of these assumptions you get into
more modern 20th century quantum
mechanics or or relativity theory things
like that
but the point is
based on the basic assumptions that we
make that is really the driving force of
what make allows us to do something
meaningful or
or powerful with an example like this
same thing with population growth the
fundamental i mean one of the earliest
choosing
one of the earliest
uh
models for population growers was built
in the late 19th late 18th century where
malthus the malthusian model
which was the first time a scientist
tried to understand how
are the resources on earth going to keep
track with the population growth and you
build a population model based on this
assumption
that change in population is
proportional to current population right
because current population includes a
certain population which is reproductive
you know it can reproduce and they give
birth to a certain proportion certain
number of children
so fertility rate or something like that
so the change in population that happens
is proportional to the current
population but if you just take that
model the malthusian model it gives you
exponential growth in population
while he was able to estimate where
marcus was able to estimate that this
growth in resources or food production
will only be geometric rate
so his prediction was that human beings
are in trouble because our food
growth will not keep pace with the
population growth which is going to be
exponential but this is not completely
accurate i mean this is true to a
certain extent this had to be modified
to make more sense of it that there is
an environment limit to the population
as you
reach the environmental limit the
population growth
growth slows down and gives you a
population growth which is not
exponential but what we call logistic
growth right so the point i mean if you
even if you don't know what
the phrases i mentioned or technical
phrases even if you don't know what
those things are i'm just trying to make
the point that as you make these
assumptions they help you drive help
drive the model forward and give power
to the assumptions that you're working
with
so
now we come to the first first part of
the talk right so if if this model this
process makes sense you know whether you
go this way and this way and things like
that
and we do this this these steps to
understand some phenomena the question
is where are ethical concerns important
in this process as we go through
so
if you look at this very first step
right so when you're working with a
if it's a pure mathematical formula
which is very rare in real life okay
maybe then you don't have that many
concerns but in reality what you end up
doing is you're using some
numerical or computational technique
based maybe if you're using machine
learning kind of thing then you actually
are looking at some data
from the real world using part of that
data to build an algorithm a machine
learning algorithm or something like
that to come up with certain conclusions
about what's really going on in this
particular model so there you must have
heard of algorithmic bias which is which
has been a buzzword a hard word for last
five ten years that uh when you use
these kind of
machine learning techniques or other
algorithms there is a danger of
introducing some sort of bias so this is
where
ethical concerns come into this
particular step of the process you can
think about what happens in terms of the
algorithms you're using are they biased
in some particular way
in the second step in this particular
step when you're interpreting math into
the real world
here's an example of that bioethics when
you're doing when you're working with
models for for example drug delivery
systems or you're working with models
which talk about how medicine a
particular drug is absorbed in the body
or how it stays in a particular body
how what kind of useful and harmful i
mean no medicine is completely just
beneficial there are always side effects
right so how when you build a
mathematical model to see how those side
effects affect you you have to interpret
the conclusions
because they are going to apply to real
people to patients right so in that
interpretation and application bioethics
is an important thing this this has been
studied for ages ever since we have
modern
medicine or pharmaceutical companies
bioethics is an important part of the
process because you're trying to use
some idealized mathematical model and
its interpretations and then trying to
say something about
whether or not to apply those to real
people so bioethics is an important part
so that that corresponds to that's an
example of something
so this step verification i mean a lot
of you
must work with statistical models and
things like that here's where data
becomes important right if there is bias
in your data that you're trying to build
that you're trying to validate this
against then
that data bias or statistical bias might
cause you to have erroneous conclusions
about whether a particular model is good
or not
this is where data bias creeps in here
as well because now nowadays we use
algorithmic methods which depend on a
portion of the data that you have to
train your algorithms for doing
something like this
so so algorithmic bias bioethics
statistical ethics or data bias all of
these things are sort of things which
people recognize and have been working
on or thinking about for a long long
time so the point my point is even
before you do all that
here is the very first step which is
often ignored
because oftentimes people work with oh
this is the standard way in which we
reduce this behavior to this particular
model this is the standard model or this
is a standard way in which we do things
so often this step is standardized you
know maybe you can think of examples in
your own career in your in your own
profession that when you look at certain
standard real real-world behavior you
have a description of that in your own
technical language which basically says
oh this is the standard way in which we
interpret
so when when things get standardized
there is always danger of being making
the assumption that this is the way to
do it and there is nothing wrong with it
so you make that implicit assumption
that this is unbiased or or you just
ignore the possibility of ethical
concerns
so so this is the point i'm trying to
make
so so this is something that does not
get enough by play in our you know
in in our in in media in otherwise or in
within our community within the
scientific or or computational community
is that
when
we should not be ignoring this step and
we should be thinking about okay if i'm
just using standardized
way of doing things whoever told you
your leaders in your field told you this
is a standard way of doing things we
should be questioning where those
standards come from
are they unbiased so if we if our that
very first step is creating some sort of
an inbuilt bias
then it's possible that we cannot
overcome that bias even if you do
everything else perfect
even if we avoid any bias in our
computations even if we avoid any bias
in our statistical or data collection
analysis even if we avoid any bias in
our real world recommendations if there
is an implicit bias in how we are doing
this
it is going to affect everything else
and it's important for us to
step back and understand what's
what those choices are implicit most of
the time those are implicit choices that
we have made are those choices
that's really the point of what i'm
trying to try to say sort of bring that
to the forefront
uh so i pause for a moment and see if
anybody has any question or comments
till this point
okay
i can't see faces so i'm just okay okay
i'm still here okay good
everybody's still here okay uh
okay so then let me if there are no
questions then i'll continue um
so i i mean
there could be a whole talk about what
does ethics exactly mean and what do i
mean by ethical standards so i'm not i'm
going to reduce
several thousand years of mathematical
thinking or sorry of human thinking or
philosophical thinking to a single slide
right so that's you know welcome to a
short talk right so
so here are some perspectives on ethical
standards you know utilitarian will my
choice create the most good and because
um
rights which choice best respects the
rights of those who have a stake i'm
going to talk about a couple of examples
which are sort of in terms of
utilitarian or or fairness and justice
perspective
uh here's uh i'll have a couple of
advertisements if you want to learn more
about
real-world
examples of ethical decision-making and
real-world case studies
uh markula center for applied mathematic
applied ethics sorry is uh is a great
place to do that if you do a google
search for this you'll find
a huge variety of real world case
studies which talk about
when ethical decision making is
important so that i
i don't have time to talk too much about
that
okay so what i'm going to do is now my
real talk is starting i'm going to give
you a quick overview we don't have so
much time
uh i'm going to give you a quick
overviews of two examples of of trying
to illustrate this kind of thing so the
first example will be a historical
example to illustrate how this
bias can
create issues with what we are trying to
do even especially when we are trying to
help people or when we are trying to
understand how certain situations affect
people
and second will be a personal example of
our attempt of my attempt to make sense
of a standardized model a standardized
way of designing transportation systems
and trying to ask the question
can we
rethink what assumptions we are making
in that model and apply it to a
situation where these ethical concerns
are important the question of equity
equitable distribution of resources is
important so i'll give you two quick
overviews of these two examples
so uh i won't go through the whole
timeline but this is the first example
this is the historical example called
the love canal controversy
uh has anyone heard of the love canal
controversy this was a big hot thing in
1970s and 80s maybe before most of you
were born maybe i don't know
uh so this was this was a big thing
because it this was one of the one of
the early indicators of uh controversy
about environmental concerns in in our
day-to-day life in in the united states
particularly
so love canal was a was a small is a
small it was a small suburban town in
new york state close to niagara falls
and and it was named for wt love who
built the canal over there for a
hydroelectric plant which was never
built there is
an electrochemical factory was
established in 1905.
in 1942 1952 this company was allowed to
dispose several thousand tons of
chemical waste in the canal in fiber and
metal
they had they had nowhere else to put
this waste so they put it there
by 1953 the canal was full so it was
covered by soil and grass grew
1956 in the in the boomer generation as
as uh in the post-world war two
generation as the number of children
grew really really fast the population
was growing a lot of young children so
there was demand for new schools so a
new school was built in the suburb of
niagara falls city in the city near
there in buffalo near buffalo
and
soon a town town a bedroom community
grew around that
now let's move to 1970s chemical orders
became noticeable in the city soon there
were newspaper articles and there were
investigation and the new york
department of health found that there
are lots of chemicals including
carcinogens in the city not surprisingly
right
for us from this perspective
so then they had to come up with okay
what should we do so there is it's
dangerous to live there so the so the
new york department of health came up
with the proposal that
they will buy the houses which are
closest to that particular site
and relocate those
residents
so and they and they concluded based on
their
study which i'll soon talk about they
concluded that rest of the canal far
from the waste site to save the living
so nothing for those people i mean you
need to
they need to continue
so in in the same as as this was
happening uh lewis gibb who was a
homemaker she organized a residence
association and she sat down with a map
of love canal of this of the town
and put a pin on every home with a
registered health problem
and soon she noticed as she put on these
you know so this was the center part
and
this is where the waste site was right
and as she put these pins
off where the houses with
health problems were
she noticed some sort of a strange
pattern it didn't look completely random
it looked like some sort of a pattern
and then what she noticed was this
pattern actually corresponded to when
she talked to older people and she
talked looked at the old maps of the
city
it these patterns these marks sort of
corresponded to certain o to all uh
sorry seasonal streams
streams which get water only in certain
seasons and swales
so so these would be the the swales
because remember they were connected to
the love canal itself and that's where
the waste site was
so she so so let's call these things wet
homes the homes which correspond to
which were on these parts of old streams
and squares
so when they did a thorough survey of
all the residents with help of
with help of beverly pagin a cancer
researcher from nearby research
institute they found that residents in
red homes were three times more likely
to have different kinds of health
problems than those in the dry homes the
homes which are not already
okay so
so they argued that based on this they
argued that evacuations would prioritize
residents from white wet homes and
ultimately all residents should be
evacuated because of this widespread
pattern of contamination through the
soils
but nydh new york department of health
disputed this and that said they would
only evacuate houses close to the west
side with enough media coverage and all
kinds of controversies finally finally
they prevailed and much of the penalties
and this is how this was one of the
major impetus to you must have heard of
superfund sites
all major cities all areas of the u.s
have certain superfund rights which are
sites
created to handle sites of major
environmental disasters
and
in 1980s because of this because of a
way to handle this this situation in
love canal
the federal government created these uh
created funded funding for these
environmental protection agency
supervisors anyway so so it has a
important historical importance for all
of us who live here in the united states
so okay what's the point so that was a
story so the point i'm trying to make
here is okay what's really going on
right there was this dispute between
pajan and and the new york department of
health scientists because they were
basically working with different
mathematical models
in case of nydh scientists they built a
mathematical model based on the
assumption that toxins spread more or
less homogeneously outward from the
from the waste site right so if this is
my way side
it it all sort of spreads
homogeneously like this and as you get
farther and farther away
from the
uh from the contamin the main waste side
the effect of the contamination becomes
less and less
okay
and this is this was this is traditional
scientific practice right you start with
this kind of a basic assumption you
build a model on that and then you add
complexity to use too but the
fundamental assumption doesn't change
that the fundamental assumption is that
as you go farther from the waste site
the effect of the waste will become less
in case of paige and her analysis her
model was based on
the fact that
toxins spread faster through
the paths created by seasonal streams
and swims so that created a completely
different model
then
the question is okay what do you do i
mean so you have two very different
approaches to the same problem then the
question is what is the burden of proof
in case of the nyds scientist they said
we need strong evidence that love canal
is unsafe
because we have this standardized model
which works you know which works which
works in most situations this is the
correct way to do things
so if you want a claim that is unsafe
you need to give me give us strong
evidence that there is it's not unsafe
in case of patient
her point was that strong evidence is
needed to conclude love canal is safe
since a mistake could remain result in
damage to human life in the context of
the history and available data because
you're not looking at the data you're
making this assumption of homogeneous
spread well it is heterogeneous
spread and then when you do the
statistical i mean when you do the
statistical modeling and when you do the
validation statistically
it will create wrong conclusions because
your fundamental model is based on
homogeneous spread rather than
heterogeneous which is really what seems
to be happening
and more importantly
in the context of the history of the
situation there is
reason to believe that there could be
damage to human life
so this is an example of so this is one
of the things i want to advertise is
that this is an example of what is
called the precautionary principle
so this was this originated in 1970s or
even earlier historically
and and in in the rio declaration of
1992 uh representatives of one 178
nations agreed on the statement that
when there are
threats of
serious or irreversible damage lack of
full scientific certainty shall not be
used as a reason for postponing
cost-effective measures to prevent
environmental degradation
so you can see this is a very of course
it's very vaguely written because you
know all of these things are open to
interpretation but this is sort of like
a principle about
when there is a threat of environmental
degradation we should be
looking in terms of damage to human life
right so when you're making some
decisions when you are creating a
an algorithm when you're creating a
computational technique when you're
working with a mathematical model and
it's not just an abstract model in an
abstract space your conclusions or what
your algorithm does has an impact on
people how they live their life how what
happens to them what they use
maybe it's just a
algorithm you wrote for cleaning up
photographs but the data you used or the
assumptions you may use where that oh it
will it's basically just people who look
whose skin color looks like a particular
color
while people who have a different skin
color
are not even considered in that
particular algorithm or in the
particular data that you're training
that algorithm
then that will create an issue
that's an issue of a bias right so it
has an effect on people it has an effect
on people who are working and i'm not
just using this example hypothetically
this is something that actually happened
with a certain
software that samsung for example
created and i think some other companies
also
which had this kind of an issue right so
that might so so when you have
situations where
uh your
model and your your and what you're
doing with it either whether
computationally or mathematically or
statistically
we need to take it as serious situation
when it has an effect on
actual people
so so i'll end this first part of the of
the talk of this example with sort of
saying okay some some guidelines we
could say are that when you're doing
applications when you're working with
real life the practitioners are not
outside the system right scientific
objectivity is tricky so just to use the
example of the nydh scientist there is
no i mean i mean let me just clarify in
my talk that i'm not claiming that they
had some sort of they were you know
doing something bad or something uh not
fair because from their perspective what
they were doing was perfectly standard
standard scientific practice
and they were not doing something that
you know that was wrong in any any sense
of the word that was in the sense that
things were done at that particular
but the thing was
not questioning the standardized model
and just using it blindly
doesn't mean that it is true or is it
useful or is it's meaningful in all
particular situations so when we have
certain uncertainty of assumption
and
uncertainty of evidence then we should
consider that in the context of burden
and plus it's important to work in
multi-disciplinary terms when
scientific knowledge is so
stratified so segmented it's important
that we have different perspectives from
different scientific perspectives
scientific or whatever field that you're
working with i mean there is there is
this i mean if i have time later on if
somebody's interested i can tell you
about this
example which sort of makes this
important like when you work with a team
which is only consists of physicists
they will look at a particular problem
as purely as a physical phenomena
when you also need a chemical phenomenon
a chemical perspective to that
particular problem and this is an
example of that
and and local stakeholders should be
involved in the process right so if it's
going to affect people who are going to
be the consumers of what you're selling
they their perspective also has to be
considered
so uh having said that in the last
uh
10 15 minutes i'm going to talk a little
bit about okay as personally from my
perspective
what can i do about this right i mean
i'm i'm by training i'm a mathematician
so i'm already working in some sort of
abstract space right i mean i do some
computation things like that but the
thing is how do i
engage with something where i can sort
of
use my knowledge or my perspective to
say something meaningful about a real
life problem where where ethics is
important or or a mathematical model
ethical perspective
so
we looked at this question of how a
public transit system is designed so
this is a standard problem for the last
50 years this urban transit network
design problem has been well studied for
last 50 plus years
and there are many different kinds of
problems and decisions being made you
know in different mathematical models
which are used and then computed
strategic decisions tactical operations
i've given you some examples of this
and and this is based on paper with adam
as i mentioned earlier uh on on which
recently appeared in the acm conference
on equity and access and algorithms
mechanisms and optimization
which was organized by this really cool
so this is my advertisement number two
if if you are interested in
meeting or talking with other people who
are interested in uh
using computational power for social
good
this is a group called mechanism design
for social group you can if you just do
a google search for it there is a large
community of people who sort of uh
discuss things and work with things and
organize workshops
uh discussion groups things like that
related to this issue
so so so look that up and and and you
might find that if nothing else that
might be the most useful thing you find
from this particular talk
so back to our problem right so urban
transit network design problem so it's
it's basically a two level problem the
upper level corresponds to transit
policy design you know so when you're
making decisions about what should be
the costs what should be
uh the socioeconomic constraints you
know what kind of constraints should you
design the overall region-wide this
let's say chicago transit
uh transit authority transportation
authority the lower level corresponds to
the users people who are actually using
the transportation system the passengers
people like me who take the subway or
the bus to go to different parts of the
city and the travel choices they make
will be influenced by what happens over
here
and the choices they make might
influence the kind of decisions the
upper level makes because you know if
you raise the price of buses too much
and everybody starts crowding the
subways then you might have to sort of
rethink your policy because everybody is
trying to save money and getting on the
subways and they are getting overcrowded
i'm just making i mean that's a silly
example but something like that you
understand the point
and within the lower level there is
another game going on right i mean if
you think in terms of driving a car or
something like that everybody wants to
take the shortest route but if everybody
wants to take the shortest route does
that
it might become so crowded that is
completely jam-packed that nobody can
move and that does happen
so there is a game being played between
the
users at the lower level as well because
the choices they make they are
influenced by choices of other people in
that
so conceptually these two sort of
games are tied in together and together
they can be expressed as a sort of
mathematical program a mathematical uh
description with equilibrium constraints
so it's an example of a mathematical
game
so
so it so this process is
is
in the standard ways is uh modeled as an
optimization problem with underlying
game theoretical assumptions so some of
you might know or if you don't know
that's fine you know it's a kind of a
non-cooperative nash game and there is a
wardrobe equilibrium of that
and the most common so when we have
optimization problem we should ask
ourselves okay what are we optimizing
right
so the most common objective functions
objectives we are trying to maximize or
minimize are we are trying to minimize
let's say operator costs
right the number of the travel distance
the vehicle maintenance things like that
and user costs you want to minimize the
travel time waiting time walking
distance number of transfers things like
that
and these are all subject to standard
constraints or transportation network
design you know budget rebounds and how
networks interact things like that so
you know we don't have time to sort of
talk about the details of that
so the question is okay still i'm still
stuck on this question right so how
should a public transit system be
designed so i've told you how things are
done right so
it's an optimization problem with the
standard
objective functions like you're trying
to minimize user cost minimize operator
cost subject to standard uh network and
then you can tweak things i mean in
general these problems are really hard
computational
right so these these problems that you
create this way are really really highly
non-linear uh highly complicated with
lots and lots of data that you have to
work with so these are really hard so so
a lot of the work is based on okay how
do i take these models how do i
emphasize a particular objective
function or a constraint
uh to alleviate certain particular
problem maybe there is too much vehicle
crowding so how should i change it so
that there is less vapor crowding and
things like that
right
but let's let's take one step back and
ask ourselves okay
recently i mean not that reason but
about seven or eight years ago there was
a major review of this these problems
that were considered and
and what they found out was there was
exactly one paper
where the
objective functions or constraints were
not just travel time or user demand or
operational costs
the standard things right you're trying
to minimize traffic you don't care how
much pollution you're causing as long as
you minimize travel times of course
these things are interrelated
so there was only one paper which had
been which had
considered environmental health concerns
like in in the form of co2
out of thousands of papers that have
been written
so the question we had was that how
about okay here i want to
see how can we design a public transit
system to not just to work okay to bring
people to the downtown which is good
that's an important part of it but what
about community access to social
services for example do all communities
in chicago area all the neighborhood
chicago have equitable access to health
care centers to city offices to parks to
museums whatever kind of social service
you're talking
and can we improve this accessibility
and make it more accurate
so how can we do that so to to use as a
case model we have we work with the
primary healthcare
centers in chicago so these black dots
are so this is chicago hopefully all of
you recognize that and and the boundary
and the the political units or sort of
the the the
borders that i have in the map of
chicago are the official 77
uh communities that we have in chicago
uh and and these black dots are the
locations of the primary health care
centers
okay
so we have this is where private health
care centers are located and based on
i'll talk about how i measure this
accessibility based on this
accessibility metric
this is the
the green colors in the middle over here
the darker the green color so i'm not i
don't have a scale over here because
that's more complicated to sort of
describe what's happening
but these green these colors in the
middle bright green colors are the ones
which correspond to highly accessible
you can reach your primary healthcare
center very quickly and get treated over
there while these
these neighborhoods these in the south
in the south in the north northwest
south south west they are it takes a
long long time to reach a primary health
care center from from from somebody's
home on average living there
okay
so this is a situation and this is not
just situation we came up with or we we
sort of
observe for the first time this is
something which has been talked about
by
uh
city of chicago in their official
reports as well
so now the question is
how do we improve this section how how
should we improve this accessibility
so the traditional way of studying these
problems is in terms of facility
location problems
so what do we do we throw more money at
the problem like obviously we should be
building more primary care centers and
then place them optimally so that more
people have access to them build more
cta subway lines build more cta bus
lines add more cta buses but all of
these require these are slow and they
require major financial investments
which might take for political or
economic reasons that may or may not
happen and might take a really really
long time so what can i do
as somebody who might be advising the
cta or a transportation system to do
something better about this particular
problem what can i say
as an applied mathematician
so what we do is well we consider the
problem of
changing
rather than changing or added adding new
facilities we say how about we change
the transit network
so can we make changes to the transit
network in such a way that
it improves the problem that we are
trying to solve the equitable
accessibility but without making any
changes that are disruptive or expensive
right so it almost seems like you know i
want i want my cake and eat it too right
so i want i want both these things so
this is what we
so we build a model a mathematical model
along the lines of what i said so we
took a standard model and we tweaked it
so we we build a model in such a way
that
we want to build a model in such a way
that we produce solutions that remain at
or near the system's current cost and
performance level while trying to
improve the social access objective
and the design decision should consist
of measure which are low cost immediate
and easily implemented right so these
two are sort of two of the crucial
design principles over here
so i'm not i'm not going to bore you
with the mathematical description of
this thing so the main point i want to
make is that how did we achieve
something like this with a reasonable
rate of success so this is this is sort
of ignore this part the rest of it is a
very standard model for
public transit design except this and
this these two functions whatever they
are operator cost and user cost
they are usually the ones which are the
objective function you're trying to
optimize
and the decision variables we created
are basically how can we exchange buses
between different lines in such a way
that it improves accessibility to
primary healthcare
without being
disrupted so i'm going to skip over
these mathematical details if somebody's
interested i can talk more about them
later on
so we had to do something i mean this is
this is the
accessibility metric that we're using
this is a standard thing i mean one of
the motivations we had this comes from
uh geographical information systems uh
so so a lot of work and some of you
might even remember from a few years ago
a lot of work was uh was being done to
understand
uh food deserts places where people
don't have quick access to
uh fresh food
so this is a one
sort of metric used to understand how
quickly how accessible is a particular
collection of locations for example
uh
grocery stores with fresh groceries
so so we use this sort of standard
function it's highly non-linear there
are certain parameters over here and you
take those and we use that as a measure
of how crowded a particular facility is
and whether it's close to many populated
communities so so this is this is sort
of the mathematical
formulation of this principle over here
that i have
yeah
the other thing i want to say is
how do you make sure that we don't just
make the problem make
while improving the accessibility to
primary health care centers we don't
disrupt other people's accessibility to
for example their downtown jobs and
things like that or moving around the
city
so what we say is that oh you're this is
let's say this is my current operator
this is my current user cost
i'm allowed to make it worse by a really
really small amount so in our case we
use like one percent
so up to one percent i have the
flexibility to make it a little bit
worse okay so i'm going to skip over
this and and sort of
this is something that a lot of you
might be interested in i'm just giving
you one slide for this so what is what
what actually are we doing
computationally right so computationally
we're building an underlying
transportation network
which has these many nodes after certain
reduction in the
and the nodes correspond to origin
destination where people start from and
end at public transit stops communities
and primary health care centers so there
are total of these there are total of
these many arcs which correspond to
walking routes like this the cta bus and
subway lines things like that
and then all the data sources from i
mean this was before we started work on
this before 2020 census data became
available so this 2010 sensors
from the
ct cta gtfs files and healthcare data
so using all this data and and we had to
create a new algorithm to be able to
work with because it's the highly
non-linear optimization problem with
really large-scale data so it's hard to
work with this so for i'm just saying
these words for those of you who might
have experience with taboo search and
simulated annealing so we created a
hybrid taboo search simulated and
evening solution with our list
and this is what the computational
results look like so this objective
function is
the
the value of the accessibility the
objective function
and as we run the algorithm it improves
that accessibility
there is a bump over here this bump
corresponds to when we allow buses when
the algorithm starts moving buses from
regular routes to express routes so
express routes are the routes which skip
over certain they they are faster and
they skip over some less used stops and
go to the more used stops
so so let me
and at the end of these 500 stopped out
of 500 iterations because there were no
more improvements showing up so what
happens
so these are so don't worry about the
actual numbers the numbers are not these
numbers are purely used for comparison
purposes
so this is the
objective function value in terms of the
accessibility to something
so this was the initial value and this
is the final value so the mean hasn't
changed much
the median hasn't changed much
the maximum which is good right we want
things to be more accessible the maximum
hasn't changed much
but what has changed is the minimum
value so this corresponds to where
it the accessibility was very low
that has gone up by
45
standard deviation has decreased by 33
so what this means what all this means
is that
overall distribution remains relatively
balanced
things didn't things overall they moved
things moved but
what happened was the maximum value
remained the same but the minimum value
went up and the standard deviation
became less
so most cities there is an equitable
distribution of what the accessibility
is in most of the communities today
overall we have success in in terms of
what we wanted to do and all this was
done without making the overall thing
much worse right i mean we only allowed
degradation in the overall thing by a
percentage of one percent that was the
parameter
so this is how it looked initially
and after we run the algorithm 500
iterations and move some of the buses
from one line to another this is what
the accessibility looks like and you can
see
that it became more muted right there
are fewer greens but there are also
fewer red color
things everything is more grey and which
is good everything is more equitably
distributed
this thing is still deep red and i'll
and if i have time later on i'll ask you
for those i mean all of you are from
chicago you might have an idea why this
is still correct
okay and and this is a relative change
that happened so you can see this is the
transfer of resources relatively
speaking
and i'm going to stop since i am out of
time i'm going to stop and thank you for
listening and i'm going to give you an
opportunity to ask questions and we can
go back to certain slides as needed
great thank you anyone is free to
uh mute themselves or if you're more
comfortable you could also put a
question or comment in the chat
well thanks a lot he mentioned for
all the pointers
um to uh you know ethics in addition to
the
mathematical modeling principles
so i i have taken a quick look at your
paper and and i'm curious like the
the objective function values um
[Music]
seems to be very small like at the order
of like 10 to the power -4 or even five
is that correct
yeah i mean that's that's just an
artifact i mean all of those things the
actual numbers so the these objective
functions are based on let me share the
thing again let me show you the
right so that's just an artifact of
using this particular so when you use
this particular gravity-based metric
when you use these gravity-based metrics
uh
they are only useful for comparative
things
so so the actual value of the of the
objective function is in some sense
meaningless it's just it's it's used for
comparing
how things were earlier and how they
have changed whether they have improved
or worsened in terms of accessibility so
that's that's right
so
i mean your algorithm seems to be very
complex and i i i don't really
understand the
uh details but i i'm guessing that you
you show a graph like when
when the objective function reached a
plateau at the 500th iteration then the
algorithm stops so i'm imagining your
stopping condition must involve some
some some
some
change in error or objective value so
that is so no i mean we stopped it yeah
we actually stopped it way before that
we stopped it because
it's you know it's as you know it's it's
a very complicated problem so it takes a
long time so once we saw that there were
no further improvements happening we
stopped it like manually in some sense
right so after a certain point we just
stopped it not not so it didn't even
reach the point where
there was a numerical constraint on
stopping so we stopped it before that
and in the paper you can read about we
did some uh
test studies to see how sensitive or
whether it was possible to make any
improvements even in some simpler
situations based on the on the on the
data so we generated some test networks
and worked with those
and our conclusion was that it would be
not very useful to go beyond i mean it's
not going to show any major improvements
even if we went on to a thousand
iterations or something
oh so i
i mean the the at the 500 iteration
it reaches the objective value of around
10 to the power -4
but then the computational results where
you show the statistics
have uh all the uh values at the level
of 10 to the power minus 5 and and i
hope i didn't make an error in my slides
so i don't know i mean let me see okay
maybe they're different
yeah i don't know maybe that's not yeah
i mean that that picture so let me see
yeah
that's a good question i mean that could
be just
so yeah 2.6 and okay yeah and
right there is yeah you're right i don't
know why there is
this discrepancy i will have to i will
have to look into that yeah i mean i'm
not sure i don't have a good answer for
you this tend to bar the
these numbers don't seem to match up
with what i
said
no no no no no no okay no no i know
what's happening sorry i'm yeah it makes
sense so it's it's all by a factor of 10
right
right the reason is off by a factor of
10 is because this is for the community
areas there are total of around 77
community areas
so you should think of this as when you
multiply it or you know when you add up
these numbers for 77 things it will give
you something like 10 to the power minus
4.
okay
these these are the mean median standard
deviation for
or so you have a vector of data right 77
for each of the community areas because
we are trying to understand what the
accessibility is for each community
so the previous graph is maybe for just
one of these 77 no not one it's for the
sum of those things oh some more
it's the sum of those things so the
objective function is
so this is the objective function so
it's for the sum of these things i
didn't really talk about this is
actually a little more complicated than
just a simple sum
but it is basically adding them that's
right
so that's why that's the difference
okay
and i imagine like during different
hours like peak hours or off-peak hours
the um
this the data and and uh
um all these uh accessibility concern or
or just the regular user course could be
very different and they would be of
course yeah of course i mean we mostly
worked with daytime or a particular time
period in the daytime because that's
what makes more sense for primary care
health care center i mean nobody will
travel to a primary health care center
at late at night or early in the morning
it's only during the regular hours and
we do make and we do make an assumption
to make this computationally work
because this is more of a design tool or
a decision making tool it's not really a
tool for
live
updates right so this this algorithm or
this model is meant for
uh
level your upper level design
decisions that you're trying to make
it's trying to help you come up with
possibilities of making changes to the
transit system so that it shows that
kind of improvement so you would not run
it
on dynamic data you would actually run
it on static data but
you can take that dynamic data and look
at different time intervals to make
sense of what's really going on and we
picked basically one particular time
interval and sort of averaged over that
that time period right
yeah yeah
so
very interesting
have you um maybe presented this work to
um
maybe some some officials uh at the city
of chicago or heard any feedback from i
mean
yeah exactly so so so some people in the
administration in the in in iit have
been trying to get in touch with uh
people in cta but it's hard to get you
know people who are at the higher level
at cta to really talk to them so it's in
you know i'm still hopeful that maybe
uh maybe something will come out of that
and i'll be able to talk to them about
this so as a decision-making tool
basically okay
very interesting i don't want to
monopolize the q and a time
no i mean yeah anybody from the um other
participants
and and for those of you who are i know
this this group is more focused on you
know maybe computational issues so if
you are interested i mean if you
if you're interested you can send me an
email or if you just do a search for for
this particular uh paper
uh the
the paper that the second part of the
talk was based on
on archive as well as on adam's web page
we do have all uh
all the data that we used all the
algorithms all the software everything
that i mean adam did all most of the
work with the actual computational work
the writing the
uh writing the c plus plus code he used
c plus plus for it to actually make it
work otherwise it was too efficient to
do it with something else when he tried
python first and that didn't
work so well for him so he ended up
doing it with c and c plus plus
so how how
how long did it take to to maybe get to
a solution estimate for
i mean it took uh so i'm trying to
recall i think it took a few days but he
he just ran it on his on his personal
computer we didn't really get we didn't
actually try to use a cluster or
something like i think on a cluster it
would be definitely
uh would be faster
and and and the key point is we were not
really trying to optimize this in some
sense the running time because as i said
it's an offline decision-making tool so
once you run it once it sort of gives
you these different possibilities of how
to
move buses between lines so that you
have an improvement in accessibility so
so it's not something that would that
you would actually run every day or or
or you know or very often
yeah
well we have run over time so i
i'm sorry
um i better pass it back to a rebecca
sure thank you everyone um thank you
especially
uh dr cool
this has been a really unique talk we
don't often have talks like this so i
really appreciate it as well
okay
nice to see everyone we'll see you in
the new year
thank you so much thank you everybody
thank you